the ball should be flying as austin
hayes gets in
has some power and that one driven deep
racing back pilar and he makes a leaping
catch and up against the bullpen fence
well that's the kind of defense you're
gonna see from him red sox have seen it
against them for years but he backtracks
beautifully crashes into the wall and
holds on to the baseball terrific
outfielder
that one ripped and that's gonna get all
the way to the monster
jbj trucking around
into second base with a run scoring
double jose peraza not a bad way to
start your red sox career and he makes
it one to nothing 86 mile an hour
fastball right there and he rips it
down the left field line easy double for
peraza nice way to start his career with
the red sox rvi double it took the red
sox to the bottom of the lineup to get
their first couple of hits but they
turned into a run
at second
did get something and he turned on that
and another rocket pulled to the wall
perazo scores easily first rbi of this
season for jd martinez red sox double
that lead to nothing yeah change up got
too much of the plate he'd hooked it
torn into an another one down the line
a carbon copy
in to score jd martinez
and right behind him rafael devers pilar
already putting up a really fine night
in his red sox debut and he makes it
four to nothing almost like identical to
the pitch that
jd martinez got and the red sox got it
going on
that's hammered that one deep to right
field racing back suntan dare he can't
get it it's going to bounce off into the
seats
for an automatic double another double
for the red sox he doesn't get it all
but that that's his stroke and when he
hits a ball in the nose it's out easy
little one hop into the seats two run
double
1-1
and a line shot base it into center
field
andrew benintendi in the score
as that throw is cut off martinez into
third eight to nothing boston first and
third
and that one hit the other way for a
base head that will bring in martinez
and the red sox
as xander scoots on down to third base
have opened it up here nine to nothing
on opening night
still only one out
there on the corners
base head looped into left field
and the red sox get to 10.
as xander bogart's touches home plate
rbi single for christian vasquez 10 to
nothing socks
of aldi 01
and nunez drives this one down the left
field line it's headed towards the
corner santander scores easily and going
into second base with a two bagger
is renato nunez his first rbi of 20 20
and the orioles not to be shut out
tonight in boston
native baldi certainly did his job pitch
very very well tonight over six innings
he looked like a number one five hits
just one run he looked good the stuff
was there
yeah very impressed with him tonight
with his uniform number now and seven
i don't know if the one fell off or if
he put on
christian vasquez's number but uh for
some odd reason never seen that before
no number seven's pitching right now
instead of number 17. yeah which is how
he started things tonight
there's a shot
that one driven back
toward the wall
and another one off the green
pallaran to score
vazquez right behind him jackie bradley
will drive in two runs with a double his
second double the red sox have seven in
the game
and they are on top 12 to one
you'll see jose with the mask up when
he's playing defense not required of
players to wear a mass it's a high fly
left field
that one's deep for the wall and that
one's off the monster jackie bradley
scores that is a three-hit game for jose
barraza and another red sox double give
them eight in the ball game
see he'd be very difficult against
right-handers oh ruiz with a good swing
that's way back and it is gone rio ruiz
with the orioles first home run of the
season
touch them all rio another ball middle
middle just about bell time what a good
swing that is
and the payoff pitch to ruiz
and struck him out and that's the ball
game the red sox win this one handily on
opening day 2020
as it finally gets underway and the red
sox pound out a 13-2 victory
over the orioles